foreign
volunteer group in Madrid
many Spaniards ran errands and organized
food for those in need during the
pandemic
they were honored by the EU Parliament
for their efforts
welcome to the covid-19 Special Report
long covid can lead to severe mental
health problems
we talked to psychiatrist leosha about
just how severe and why
foreign
how dangerous is the so-called twindemic
a simultaneous wave of covid-19 and
influenza infections and can it be
prevented
but first we visit a group of graffiti
artists in Zimbabwe their murals tell
the stories of women and girls during
the pandemic
[Music]
at this studio in Zimbabwe's Capital
Harare graffiti artists are working on
Concepts to help stimulate debate on
social issues made worse by the pandemic
their focus is on problems affecting
women and girls
they first visualize their ideas with
sketches on paper and on the computer
before they set to work on the murals
for us it's every imagination of our
future every imagination of our
contemporary life and also
um going back to traditional knowledge
systems you know there's been a lot of
during the coffee times we realized that
um they we we took herbs we took
concussions that were used like like 200
years ago 300 years ago that have been
passed down through the through
generations so that showed us um the
importance of traditional knowledge
system
the graffiti artists have been painting
murals on the streets of some of
harare's poorest neighborhoods
their imagery incorporates the faces of
influential women the hope is to inspire
young women and girls who have been
negatively affected by the pandemic
in Zimbabwe the number of teen
pregnancies Rose sharply during the
lockdown over four thousand girls did
not return to school when they reopened
in early 2021.
girls and women's rights Advocates say
the Arts are an effective way to
communicate and to spark change
based on the learnings and experiences
we've had from covid-19 there needs to
be a concerted investment in developing
messages that are relevant messages that
are informed by experience and evidence
messages that harness the power of the
Arts both the Visual and Performing Arts
to propel messages around girls rights
to propel messages that ensure the
protection of girls to also put forward
messages
regarding sexual and reproductive Health
rights and information
the pandemic has also shaped Zimbabwe's
Urban Street culture
fashion Collective fabric party young
people are exploring issues around
identity that took a back seat during
the pandemic
during recovery we sat down everybody
enough time to look into the internet
and see what's going on so who bless
ourselves in that space it was just a
random but now after that we're like out
we identify or how do we create an
identity for Zimbabwean culture
fabric party is developed into an art
movement that brings together graffiti
artists and fashion designers to explore
new possibilities for collaboration
when people spend two years locked down
we miss that element of a community an
element whereby can collaborate and work
as a collective ways to do that to
another couple who did it online
but soon after coffee people realize the
importance of collaboration and
Collective work
at the height of the pandemic the
artists raised awareness of covid-19 by
painting murals encouraging people to
follow Health regulations like wearing
masks and social distancing
they drew on the star power of
influencers who they painted wearing
masks
the artists planned to keep working with
the concept to spark conversations about
what Humanity can learn from the
pandemic
respiratory infections increased
dramatically during the cold season that
was even true before the coronavirus
appeared on the scene the influenza
virus in particular can lead to severe
illness
together with the rising number of
covid-19 infections experts are warning
of a so-called twin endemic but it's
possible to take preventive measures
[Music]
the global number of new infections and
deaths due to covid-19 has studied since
the end of August for the past several
months the ba4 and ba-5 Omicron
sub-variants have driven most new cases
but scientists say a number of worrisome
new subtypes are also fueling the
pandemic
in the U.S but also other places they
include three types that together now
account for around one in seven newly
reported cases there
in Europe a lineage detected first and
Asia has grown in prominence in the UK
which has a top-notch surveillance
system experts are tracking the possible
rise of still others and Indian
scientists and authorities across the
globe are chasing data on a Troublesome
variant dubbed xbb in Singapore
estimates show it could now be causing
over half of all cases
and as we come into the winter time now
we are starting to see further increases
in sarsko V2 activity
um so and part of that is being driven
obviously by these different Omicron
variants and another infection is
compounding concerns the flu earlier in
the pandemic measures that slowed the
spread of the coronavirus also helped
people avoid getting infected with other
pathogens like those causing the flu
influenza I mean like SARS cov2 is a
respiratory infection so the measures
that were put in place to reduce covid
transmission also impacted influenza
transmission so when we reduced our
mixing with other people when we reduced
our international travel
that also reduced the ability of
influenza to spread but as the urgency
of the pandemic subsides and measures
relax flu cases are also Rising again
both diseases pose a particular threat
to groups like the elderly or people
with underlying health conditions and
also to health care workers
although they may not be an elevated
risk of severe disease if they fall sick
then that also increases absenteeism
from work which has important
implications then for the workforce and
its ability to the healthcare system to
operate and of course there's also
potential risks that healthcare workers
can infect their patients as well
in an effort to head off the worrisome
scenario of a twin democ during the
upcoming winter Healthcare authorities
from the World Health Organization and
other institutions are now spreading a
simple message timely vaccination
against both diseases can save lives
[Music]
so far long covid has been Associated
primarily with extreme exhaustion and
physical pain
searches are also warning of hidden
risks more and more sufferers are
experiencing depression and even
Suicidal Thoughts we talked to
psychiatrist Leo Cher about the
development
hello Dr sure
can long covet increase the risk of
suicide is there any data or evidence to
support this there are no
epidemiological data as supporting a
link between loan covet and suicide
however many symptoms of long covet are
actually associated with suicidal behead
for example many people with long covet
are depressed it has been suggested that
at least 50 million people at least 50
million people around the world of Islam
covet developed depression and we know
that depression is associated with
suicidal Behavior
how might long covet lead to Suicidal
Thoughts many studies over many years
have shown as that physical pain and
lead to suicidal Behavior it depends on
in the obviously on individual
perceptions some people who have pretty
severe chronic pain are not suicidal
while some people with relatively mild
pain may become suicidal
also at people's Louis covet frequently
have cognitive impairments and many
Studies have shown that cognitive
impairments are associated with suicidal
Behavior could it also be related to
neurological changes in the brain after
a coveted infection there are
suggestions that they call it virus May
induce a neural inflammation and
inflammation in the brain
and it may affect mood behavior and
obviously of physical health
so yes is that is an idea that called a
long covet problems are related to a
neurobiological changes in the brain in
other words
may have and neurobiological basis so
what does all this mean for policy
makers what needs to be done to address
the situation first I would suggest that
more research needs to be done it is
possible that loan Corvette is not
really one disease one it's not really
one condition it may be a group of
medical illnesses it is very possible
obviously policy makers need to make
sure that people with long covet are
getting appropriate medical health and
obviously psychological help thank you
thank you
the coronavirus pandemic and the Ukraine
war have made it clear how crisis-prone
Global Traders Supply chains are
collapsing while transport costs are
rising dramatically as a result more and
more companies are bringing back home
production that was previously
outsourced to other countries like China
the offshoring of past decades is
turning into near Shoring as these two
examples from Argentina illustrate
[Music]
in December 2020 between the first and
the second wave of covid-19 the American
giant whirlpool and its president for
Latin America the Brazilian Joy Carlos
brega decided to set up a washing
machine factory in Argentina and export
from there after a 20-year hiatus
the plant was inaugurated this October
with the emergence of the pandemic and
with the political repercussions that we
are facing today the need to make sure
that the supply chain will not be broken
if something happens far away has
increased
for the past few decades the phenomenon
of offshoring took place by which
industries from America migrated to
China during the pandemic there was a
shortage of freight and with the war
fuel became more expensive the new
buzzword is near Shoring and opportunity
has opened up for those manufacturing
nearby
I have no doubts about that but to do
this we also have to generate not just
production but knowledge by
manufacturing here in Argentina we are
bringing knowledge potential this is how
competitiveness is created
competitiveness is not only about costs
Whirlpool had just 160 employees in
Argentina now there are 500 the company
invested 52 million dollars to produce
300 000 washing machines a year and
Export 70 to Brazil and the rest to
South America it has also reinforced its
presence in Mexico to supply the United
States quite a few Argentine companies
are taking advantage of near Shoring
like Ceramics Alberti its owner Martin
rapalini says that between 2019 and
today it has quintupled its exports to
Chile Bolivia Paraguay and Uruguay
we have pushed hard on Chinese and
European products with some targeting
lower value products and Europe
targeting higher value ones
both the war and the pandemic had a big
impact on the increase in logistics
costs and also on inflation
according to rapalini European Ceramics
companies have doubled the production
costs due to the increase in Energy
prices Gina China has had an impact but
the greatest impact has been on the
logistics level the containers that were
around two thousand dollars before the
pandemic now cost twenty thousand to
twenty five thousand dollars prices have
dropped again but they're still much
more expensive
Latin American countries with some
Industrial Development like Mexico
Brazil and Argentina can take advantage
of export opportunities in a region
traditionally focused on the extraction
of raw materials The Economist and
University Professor Leandro Mora
alfonsin analyzes the phenomenon of near
Shoring
the reconfiguration of global value
chains whether it be near showing or
French Shoring started before the
pandemic what did the pandemic do it
accelerated everything because there was
an increase in demand post-pandemic that
Supply chains were not prepared to
respond to Maura alfonsin cites a study
by the inter-american development bank
that confirms that Latin America could
replace 10 percent of China's exports to
America
Argentina must reduce its 83 inflation
but despite everything Whirlpool
believes in its new Factory but they
also hope that the cost of freight drops
after the pandemic
it's not yet at pre-pandemic levels but
it's not at the peak like it was during
the pandemic but the market has
restrictions and the restrictions are
very harsh and that is why investment in
mere Shoring is continuing to accelerate
the pandemic is still having an effect
on the global economy
do you have any questions about covid-19
our science correspondent Derek Williams
has the answers based on the latest
research and Analysis
right to cover producer dw.com
this week he answers the question does
the data show that natural immunity is
stronger than vaccination
in Berlin at least it seems like
everyone and their mother currently
either has covid-19 has just had it or
expects to have it soon regardless of
their immune status I personally know
people who've been vaccinated four times
who subsequently tested positive for the
virus and I also know people who've had
the disease two or even three times even
people who were up to date on their
vaccinations
um Omicron sub-variants are simply
really really infectious and the fact
that covid-19 is so widespread in so
many places
has made it impossible to provide simple
answers to questions like whether
natural immunity is stronger than
vaccination after all
most of us in 2022 now have our own long
highly personal history with sarsko V2
and the vaccines that were developed to
fight it
but even in the past it was hard to nail
down and and compare the power of immune
responses some studies conducted mostly
during the Delta era suggested that
disease-induced immunity was more
powerful against that variant than
vaccine-induced immunity was but there
were others that found just the opposite
there were also one showing that the two
were roughly comparable
the rule of thumb before Omicron swept
in was sort of that being infected was
roughly equivalent to a single dose of
vaccine but since it hit last winter
those variables have changed the average
person in many parts of the globe will
by now
knowingly or unknowingly likely have
been exposed to Omicron and its family
of sub-variants repeatedly
it sounds unclear I know but there are
things that the experts do pretty much
all agree on one is that attaining some
level of Prior immunity to covid-19
whether it's through vaccination or or
through infection that that reduces the
chances that you'll catch it in the near
future or catch it again in the near
future as the case may be a second is
that if you do get coveted 19 after
previous exposure or vaccination then
it's a lot less likely to be severe
number three is that most experts say
that people who've been both vaccinated
and infected so what's called hybrid
immunity that they in general exhibit
more durable and more potent levels of
immune protection and and finally
there's one last point where the pros
agree any prior immunity they say
whether it's gained through infection or
gain through vaccination
will provide some future protection from
severe outcomes
[Music]
making face masks and protective
clothing collecting food and
distributing it to those in need
the volunteers from the neighborhood
association somos tribu in Madrid lent a
hand wherever they were needed during
the pandemic and created a social
network
the association received an award from
the EU Parliament for its work
we went to meet some of the volunteers
[Music]
a familiar walk for Julia on yata morale
as she makes her way into her
neighborhood association
during lockdown palomeros became the
headquarters for locals who rallied
together to help their fellow neighbors
they created an organization called
somos tribu we are tribe
we began by coordinating all the help
that was needed in our neighborhood such
as shopping for vulnerable elderly
people going to the pharmacy or walking
their pets
one day a company contacted us and said
that they had a batch of dairy products
that they couldn't use they asked if we
wanted them and we said yes bring them
over
they did
and then we distributed the milk and
yogurt and so on
Julia came to somos tribu every morning
to help out before going to work as a
lab technician in the Gregorio marignon
hospital at the height of the pandemic
the maranion was overflowing with more
than 1100 coveted patients with hundreds
more turning up every day
what impressed me was the silence
hospital is normally allowed and lively
place always bustling with activity but
during the pandemic it was as quiet as a
cemetery and there was a kind of horror
we'd never experienced before many
people were deeply affected by what
happened then and still are
I worked in the emergency unit
we didn't have enough face masks when
the pandemic hit
there just wasn't enough material for
them
material
another founding member of Somos tribu
is Adriana pop she decided to act after
hearing of shortages of face masks and
protective clothing for health and
essential workers
I've always loved sewing so I found some
tutorials on how to make face masks
I used my daughter's bed sheets to make
them
the first person who asked for a mask
was a bus driver
that's when I started in earnest
I set up a WhatsApp group of women who
knew how to sew we got in touch with
health workers who didn't have masks and
gowns and got to work
we made these masks for fruit Sellers
and grocery store workers
these were nice for young people we made
these ones with cartoon characters for
children a lot of kids had a hard time
understanding what was going on
Adriana wasn't scared even though she
delivered masks to people working in
essential services
became sick
people would suffer
cousins so I didn't think about myself
one of the most important AIDS provided
was the distribution of food to the
elderly struggling with lockdown and
families unable to go out because they
had come down with covet 19. again
coordinated all the food that was
packaged and sent out from palomeras
the few of us who had cars brought food
to people's homes here's where we set up
a food bank
over there was a Fruit Stand and over
there was rice lentils things like that
at first we prepared more than 80 food
baskets a day for families that's a lot
whole apartment buildings had come down
with covid we left the food at the main
entrance and the residents handed it out
we couldn't go inside elderly people's
homes so we left the food at their front
door
then we called them to say we brought
the food our only contact with people
was by phone
these are the Flyers we first made with
phone numbers on them
we put them in our cars so that the
police wouldn't fine us for breaking
lockdown
the Highlight for somos tribu was
receiving the European Citizen Award
from the European Parliament
Brussels gave us the award you can read
about it online
last year in March members of the
European Parliament came to a park
nearby to give us their recognition
and in November we went to Brussels to
collect our award
no longer exists its Legacy lives on in
other groups that serve smaller
neighborhoods in the vaishas district of
Madrid the center at palomeras is a
resource that supports vulnerable women
but they still distribute food to the
elderly and help people who are
suffering the impact of long covert
[Music]
that's it for today see you next week on
the covid-19 special till then stay
healthy
[Music]
[Music]